كما تستمر هذه هي الحرب فانها تشكل تهديدا
لامننا وكذلك لامني حلفائنا ولا طالما هي
مستمره ستواصل تدميرها للاقتصاد الدولي
ثلثي
اعضاء مجموعه العشرين يعانون من معدلات
تضخم اكثر من سبعه بالمئه وسيكون هناك
ركود في العالم هذا عام اول
كنا بالكاد خرجنا من الجائحه
العقوبه كانت بمواجهه هذا المستقبل
لهذا المنتدى لكن هذا العام كما اكدت همم
احداث ليله امس ان الوضع هو سياسي
وتهديد المتواصل على امننا همم
هو ما يدفع كلنا ان نكون في هذه القمه
المسؤول ما من احد لم يشعر باثار حرب بوتن
على اسواق الغذاء العالميه التي
كتاب السبب
انقطاع الواردات من الحبوب الاوكرانيه
وكذلك بوقف الغاز
الروسي
علينا من ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
ان الاستقرار
والثقه في الاقتصاد
الاقتصاديه وهذا يجعل الدول الاعضاء
تعمل جاهده لخفض الاسعار وايجاد الفرس
والظروف
الاقتصادي بريطانيا والاقتصادات العالميه
لان تعود
بها وكذلك تعزيز الاسس الاقتصاديه الدوليه
والقيام بالالتزامات لمساعده الاكثر هشاشه
وتقليل الاعتماد على الوقود الاحفوري
في حين انهما من دوله
قادره بمفردها انتم تقود الاقتصاد العالمي
ودا اشكر الرئيس الاندونيسي في الاستضافه
هذه القمه
ومواجهه التحديات واا سندني همم على هذه
الاسس ونضع خطته لرجال الدوله
[موسيقى]
التي يحتاجونها شكرا لكم
اسئله من الصحافه وستبدا بكريس من البي بي
سي
شكرا لك
همم سي الرئيس بوتين قال ان هذه انا
الصواريخ التي يقال انها في بولندا على
الاراضي بولنديه انا اساسها روسي قال انها
ليست كذلك
هل يمكن ان يدفع ذلك
حلفائنا وكلنا اتفقنا هذا الصباح انه مهم
جدا
لفرقنا لان تضع الوقائع هناك فرق على
الارض تقوم
شكرا شكرا
وسنتريك عمليه التحقيق تنتهي لنعرف
نتيجتها وجود هذا الحوار هو بسبب ان
روسيا اطلقت اكثر من 80 صاروخ على البناء
التحتيه وعلى المدنيين في اوكرانيا
عندما استيقظت في الخامس صباحا
وسمعت عن هذه الصواريخ التي وصلت على
مقربه من بولندا هل هذا دفعك لمزيد من
القلق
رد فعل كان اتصالي برائيس بولندا
واننا نقف معه وما شعبه والمساعدهم فيما
يحتاجونه
بلدي هو اول ان اشير ان ما وقع يوم امس هو
امر
صعب وتحدث الى
الرئيسكي
وتحدثنا حول ما يحدث على الاراضي
الاوكرانيين اكثر من 80 صاروخ
هذا ما يحدث وهذا كان يحدث في الوقت الذي
كانت تجتمع فيه مجموعه ال20 لمحاوله
التوصل الى حلول لتحديات العالم لكنه همم
اختارا يعني بوتن ااه ان همم
يطلق صواريقه على اوكرانيا في ذلك الوقت
وبالتالي
ابراهيم ابراهيم
اجتماعاتنا عن هذه الهجمات
الهجره القسريه
[موسيقى]
الذي نواجهه على اراضينا
الاساسي
فهو يتسبب ااا انزعاج بين افراد الشعب
لانهم يبقون قلقينا من تسديده فواتيرهم
واهم شيء ان نقول له ان هذا هو تحدي عالمي
ولهذا خذنا بنقاشات مع القيادات التي تحضر
هذه القمه وتحدثنا عن همم
رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه على هامشي قمه
العشرين والتي اكد فيها وبشكل المباشر
عبارات واضحه حمل فيها بوتين مسؤوليه ركود
الاقتصاديه وقسمتي الثقه والغذاء التي
اصابت العالم وفي اجابته على عدد من اسئله
الصحفيين التي ركزت بشكل كبير على سقوط
صاروخ في هولندا قال ريشي سوناك انه هناك
تحقيقات تجرى وليست هناك اجابات واضحه حتى
اللحظه ولكنه اشاره في خضامن عرضه ل-
مواقف متعدده انا روسيا سبق واطلقت اكثر
من 80 صاروخا على البنا التحتيه
الاوكرانيه بالامس فقط وبالتالي قال انه
سرع بالاتصال برئيس بولندا